[音楽]
筑波大学のサッカー部に所属しています
その傍ら
株式会社シェア取れという会社の代表取締役も染めています
そう言うと多くの方がなんで学生がつかも体育会で企業なんかしてるのと思うかもしれ
ません
あのそのきっかけが大学1年生の頃にありました大学1年生の頃に初めて少年サッカー
のコーチを経験しました
そこである衝撃的な光景を目にします
それは相手のお父さんコーチが子どもたちに怒鳴りつけて子どもたちが泣きながら
サッカーする場面でした
僕は最初信じられませんです
だって子供が好き始めたサッカーを指導者のせいで嫌いになっていく子どもたちが
たくさんいたんです
でも最初指導者浦々みました
いろんな過ごしなって話を聞いていくうちに実は一番困っているのはし動作がちなん
だってことがわかったんです
どういうことかというと
指導者の多くが平日自分の仕事をして土日の休日を
返上してまで教えに来てくれる熱のある形です
そういった方たちやらなきゃいけないことたくさんあります様々なタスクがあります
例えば
選手の書籍管理とか練習試合の相手探しとか中でも一番大変なのが練習メニューの作成
実施です
こういった服をなんと年間300時間以上もボランティアでこなしてるんです
僕はこのデータを見た時にこういった指導者たちを作りたいと思います
そこで考えたのがこちらですトレーニング共有プラットフォームシアトルという
サービスです
料理メニューの共有サイトを多分知っている方が多いといいます
それの指導者バージョンへのサービスです全国の指導者が自分の持って練習メニューを
投稿して共有できる良いベニューがちゃんと蓄積されていくようなサイトになってい
ます
今では
このサービスなんと年間3万人の人が月間です
月間3万人の指導者が使うサービスになっています
こうやっていると一転その順調にきてるんじゃないかと
今だけビジコンで入賞してたら
そう思うかもしれませんがいろいろ大変なこともありましたん
結構僕普通でいたいタイプだったので例えば起業した次の日から急に胃が痛くなったり
とか
毎日 hp が削られていく感覚になるんですね
また休学をしているんですが休学書類を出したまた次の日からへんな頭痛に襲われまし
た
ん
会社の事を考えるだけで頭が痛くなるそういった病気に襲われますそれは運よく一緒に
立ち上げた会社のメンバーの人にカウンセリングしてもらったら直りました
そうやって大変な思いをしながら今年に入ってあるプログラムに参加しました
それはメーカー人リバーシティと言って全国の学生の中でこういう新しいことをやって
みたいとかそういう思いがある人が
60人くらいですね集まって8か月間切磋琢磨するプログラムです
かつその学生たちに一人ある企業の社長さんがメンター先生としてついてくれます
僕はこの pixta の駒田さんという方がメンターについてくれました
その方が僕にこういう言葉をかけてくれました
本当に自分がやりたいことをやっている
僕に行ってきます
僕はすぐ入っていなかったですね
なぜかというと今まで義務教育の中で決められたレールの上を歩く
人生しか送ってこなかった自分からすると
他の人と違うことをやることってすごい恐怖で本当に耐えられませんです
だからこの先企業でやっていけるかどうかってすごい不安だったんです
就職した方が楽なんじゃないかマーレと同じ道を言ったほうが考えずに済むんじゃない
かそう思っているところを見透かされています
どっちにしようか迷っている時にまたこんなことをもらいます
そういう時は一回自分のエゴと向き合って皆
ego って聞くとなんか一見わがままとか自己中とかそう感じる方が思うと多いと
思うんですけども
も創刊しましたでもそうじゃないと
ego って
自分が他の人に反対されてもやり通したいことそしてこれをやり通せる人って
自分の人生に自分で責任を持てる人なんです
他人のレールの上を歩く人生って誰かのせいにできるんです例えば会社のせいとか環境
のせいとかパニーノ線にできたんです
でも自分がやりたいことを突き通して
そういった人生歩いてる人って
自分の性にしかできないんですね
だからそういう覚悟を持っている人しか英語は見つけられないんだと言われます
みなさんは自分の英語を持っていますか
自分が本当に人生やりたいことをやってますか
周りに流されたりしてませんか
僕はずっと流されていました
じゃあどうしたら自分の英語に気付くのか見つけられるのか
その方法を僕は8ヶ月間ずっと繰り返してました
ん
それを今日は3つご紹介しますひとつ目
セルフトーク自問自答んです呪文自問自答です
自分と対話してみてくださいでただ対話するだけじゃなくて
自分の構成を見つけなきゃいけません
自分がいつ1日の中で感情が揺れ動くか
例えば同じ映画を見てなくタイミングが違う人って言いますよね
そのように自分の感情の動く時が個性が現れるときですなので一日の中で楽しい時
嬉しい時悲しい時怒った時でもいいです
1自分がそういう感情があるのかをちゃんとメモしてください
その中で自分の感情がわかったら
それに対してなぜを繰り返してください
なんで自分はの時楽しいと思ったんだろう
そうするとまた違う答えが入ってきます
これに対してまたなぜてぶつけてくださいそうすると自分の感情のより奥深くまで
潜れることができます
そして2つ目
尊敬する人をリストアップしてみてください皆さん
あの子をカッコイイとか誰々がか誰々を尊敬するとかそういう
人物が何人かいると思いますそういう人もう片っ端から書いてみてください
そしてその人々の特徴どこをカッコイイと思うのかをまだからに書き出してください
そうすると特徴の中にある共通点が見えてきます
その最大公約数を見つけて下さい
その最大公約数が自分が将来になりたい姿あっ
自分が
無意識的に憧れている姿であります
それをつかめていると自分はこういう人になりたいんだなというのがわかります
そして最後に
両親や死因について自分のことを聞いてみてください
ただ聞くだけではありません自分はどういう時に嬉しそうにしているかとかどういう時
に目を輝かせているか
どういう時にワクワクしてるかとか
小さい時とか一番そういう個性が出るときなんですがみなさんたぶんほとんど記憶ない
ですよね幼稚園の頃とか
そういう時の教皇分かっているのは8神です
両親に小さい時どういうことが好きだったのかとか聞いてみてください
僕は実際に聞いてみましたすると返ってきた答えが
お前は小さい時からいろんな意味わかんないものを作ってそれを友達に渡してこれで
死ぬあそぼって言って
これで可能損したよ
本当にもう意味わかんないですねこれとか何作ってるのか僕も今見ても何作って誰か
分からないんですけどすごい球そうにしてますこれ
これを見た時に僕ある記憶がよみがえってきたんですねそれは1年間会社をやってきて
一番たの一番嬉しいと思った瞬間だったんですけどそれはある
ユーザーの方シェアトレを使ってくれてるユーザーの方に初めて会った時なんですけど
その方に言われた言葉が
このサイトのおかげですごい指導が楽になりました子どもたちも楽しんでくれてます
このサイトを作ってくれて本当ありがとうございましたと言ってもらえた時に心の底
からもううれしいという感情が湧き出てきたんですねそのその体験とこの体験がすごい
リンクしましたどういうことかと言うと自分が一番嬉しいって感じるタイミングは
自分にしかできないものを作ってそれで他人が人が感謝してくれた時に
一番満足するんだなということが僕はわかったんです
これが腹に落ちた瞬間に僕はこのこの瞬間を人生の中で一番1泊
味わいたいそう思いましたそれが自分の英語がなってきていたんです
じゃあどういう生き方をすればいいかそう考えたら就職という選択肢はなくなります
起業して自分の新しいアイデアをどんどん生み出してそれでどんどんいろんな人に感謝
してもらい人生が自分で一番幸せな人生だなって気づけたんです
だから今覚悟を持って取り組めています
僕は皆さんに起業して欲しいわけではありません
一人でも多くの人に自分が本当にやりたいことを掴んでエゴを知って
そして後悔のない人生を生きてほしいと思ってい
今までゆとり教育とかいろんな教育をされてきましたが結局はみんなと同じことが良い
とされている教育です
人と違ったことをすることに多分皆さん恐怖があると思いますでも自分の本心を
ちゃんと掴んでいれば
エゴに向かって
することができるのです周りと比べない人生自分が本当にやりたい人生を迎えると思い
ます
ぜひ今日の
ご紹介した3つのこと
やってみてください
皆さんのエゴがわかってそれに向かって行動できる人が一人でも増えれば
以上なりますご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]